life on the road it is taco tangra
course refers waving guns and these
fights get look like running with the
runs dome blacklist bounced checks great
a bachelorette comes in the front making
out for yourself and that likes doing
ball more missing merge turn tribal
rental car has another mega church to
induce keys vagina Pfister cellphone is
gone one big ball and order
I got a poker game on the side of the
town monday night poker game that I'm
just starting back to playing I was a
stay-at-home dad for like the last four
months so now I'm getting out of the
house it was good super challenging but
my brother's been doing had an awesome
you know like everything else it was
[ __ ] great at times and I wanted to
[ __ ] shoot myself in the head other
times just like life with one kid was
one kid yeah I don't know how anybody
does it with more I know my mom had four
she did it like effortlessly was your
dad not around no he was around okay and
he was actually a burn you know very
progressive like you have to help that
laundry it wasn't like a big deal that
he did he did everything help clean did
laundry do whatever they both but I'm
still for kids all right now forget
about it man hey thanks for turning the
road stories i am your host marie
valeriano uh what's going on how are you
guys doing today everything good with
your life uh shoot me an email let me
know what's happening i'm adjusting some
some knobs here nah I'm 12 years old
I've been hanging out three and a half
year old knobs are funny to me you want
to talk but Slater I can do 10 minutes
on butts and farts what do you want I'm
kind of on the road I'm I've moved my
portable studio uh to a different studio
to the to the studio of one comedian
named Todd glass how you doing buddy I'm
doing good I really appreciate you doing
this man I'm happy to do it I you know I
love I'm only by preface everything I
say um you know you'd called me last
year and the reason I go I gotta do his
podcast and I was gonna tell you this
off the air but I was like I want to do
it right mainly like for a reason it's
not even important but like when I was
doing all those fixing the air
conditioning last year at the fest year
before yeah yeah and like you know
trying to make it work and I think I did
I did something I really you know not
just that you were I felt like you were
the ones sort of acknowledging it made
me feel so good I'm like Mary really
gets to you I really were you know you
do it because you want to make a
situation right but a little accolade
you know right here Mary's giving me all
the accolade I need over there I got it
he seems like I should do his podcast
well this is lawless is done what
happened this was at the Los Angeles
podcast festival is the stand up
aight i think i was hosting that night I
was hosting with hands foot and mouth
disease i don't know if i told you that
part no I was I don't if you remember
this but I was really sick I remember I
do remember that you asked it pretty
well on stage yeah yeah and I got a
separate microphone because it was
literal I was driving to the festival
and the doctor called and said your son
has hand foot and mouth disease that's
what you have click like it was a
message and I called her back I'm like
what does that mean and then I read
that's highly contagious like I'll man
the last thing I want to do is go to
this comedy festival and give everybody
you know our thousand people hands foot
and mouth disease but turns out it's not
very contagious through adults so
ill-used a separate mic I didn't find
that out to the day after so I was
completely paranoid I hardly took
pictures with anybody I didn't shake
anybody's hand I got a separate
microphone and but but having to but for
some reason the festival the show like
it was like 90 degrees well again and I
should just in case they do I admire so
much because I'm very particular
everything of that festival every year
it was great from the year one but here
they whatever it is they fix it just the
way you want to see it like yeah wow
that got better this year and better but
there was a problem with air that year
and I always believe I can fix most
problems i'm a good troubleshooter right
so it was freezing in the lobby the air
was working there but in the rooms it
wasn't so they didn't have any fans but
I'm like I'm gonna fix this and there's
like 400 people there's 400 people hog
room cool in the lobby so it's like what
do we do there's cool air out here can
we waft it in there and to waft it in
there you so I was like asking the
manager who was really nice of the hotel
he goes we do have those things like you
know when there's a flood and they have
to dry it there these weird-looking
there these we're looking like they
almost look like good a snail shell they
wrap around and yeah blow air like at
this big tubes going from the right and
but they had the tubes off it looks like
something would power a one of those
jumpy things like the bounce house i
bounce house like that big of it and it
blew air so you know and they weren't
that noisy so he put him out in the
lobby got about three three of them and
we open the doors in the back and he you
know i'll go long with this when people
aren't and what would
bothers me sometimes and it shouldn't
it's my own thing is that when people
aren't good weighing one bad against the
other in other words there will be noise
and I don't like noise right so if it
wasn't that hot in there if it was like
it so then it's not [ __ ] worth doing
yeah when it's that hot people go yeah
we'll take a little bit annoying and
that's what it did and within I think
three minutes the room was really nice
yeah yeah it wasn't it won't blink
that's a little better but it still
sucks no it was great and then you were
like keeping you were feeding my you
know whatever that is my ego be like God
you dead look at you and I'm like I love
this I was super impressed man that you
would lend the reason I died was
probably more I don't know I was gonna
say infatuated but that's the wrong word
more intrigued although I could be
infatuated who knows more intrigued was
the first time I ever I don't know not
known you or talk to you which you
probably don't even remember this was
Jackie k shins original podcast was
phone in and I was on as a phone in
guest and you were on as a phone in
guest but you were in I don't know
Philly or sailing on the road all right
maybe you're at helium or something and
you were you were on your phone and
you're going around fixing the tables
and the lighting in the club oh I did
that actually on the podcast yeah yeah
yeah I was on the outs on the other
phone on the other side listening to
this waiting to talk cuz I felt bad i
was like i have to do this but I'm doing
she was do it on the air or something
like she was just bragging and I was
like doing my my spin on clubs a good
old helium in Philadelphia now is that
something you do you find a lot do you
think I you by the way it just to make
this very I could talk about this 100
more times so my paranoia isn't because
I'm tired of talking about because i'm
tired i'm worried people are tired of
talking about it so I'll make it quick
okay uh yeah I do I go in the clubs and
I do my thing and most clubs they all
let me cuz you know do it myself
sheriff's usually simple stuff like you
know like I go in all I like things a
little darker than usual i wanted to
write music playing and crowds walking
in so I usually yeah I put my spin on
all the clubs and lately I've been trial
billing different markets but I have a
two piece like drums and a keyboard are
you travel with that what you travel
with that no I have I get them and every
more okay and then I'll have them play
jazz as people are coming in so people
walk into the club it's like got a red
glow to it because will gel some of the
red gel lights down and then they walk
in there's like two guys with suits or a
guy and a girl wearing black you know
badge as it just makes the whole
experience you travel with your own gels
I do keep some gels in my bag you know
what gels are of course right I know
gels are be my son-in-law she is what a
gel oh my gosh oh those shoes the dude
war in a big lebowski what are ya the
I'm gellin uh-huh how's that really is
that cuz I feel like I've heard you
several times on podcast but I've never
know I don't think I've ever like you
talk about it I keep them because
sometimes the green room will be a
little too bright so they're like you
know those things last forever you rip
them off or they stay and I grab new
ones every soft and I'll go over to
michael's here in Los Angeles but a lot
of times it's for my hotel room because
I like to invite people back to the
hotel not big enough and there's like a
sofa area and you know it what you get
just from gelling one or two lights red
or blue whatever I change it around and
then people walk into a room that's red
and there's some cool jazz music playing
and they walk in you're smoking pot you
light a candle you said around it like
it's the fire pit no and then so yea
though and those gels are like night and
day doesn't my thing is I always say it
doesn't change the room a little it's
[ __ ] really big deal people walk in
there like wow this is nice to put a
blue bandana over a lamp in college same
thing yeah you know yeah same thing I
don't know what a gel was back there
really the gels don't catch on fire
anything yeah but um but anyway yeah but
you can't wear your gels around your
head yeah it could in your lover boy
cover band okay that's that real you'd
and you bring people back to your room
yeah a lot of times like you know people
you just met or the opener or you know
um usually it'll be some people from the
club right uh but definitely the other
comedians like all the times you know if
if you're friendly to the other
comedians the first time you're in the
next time here and they come around and
you remember them you might have friends
you only see once a year you know the
deal um but yeah like sometimes even
seven people you know just come back to
the room it's in order room service you
all right what are some pizzas back to
the room and if there's no we're cool to
go hang out you know I know that I'm
gonna walk into like tranquil atmosphere
it's all set up it's ready to go you got
the jazz trio in the corner at the gym
that's actually not a bad idea you
should do it hey man I'm pretty good on
the guitar are you really oh yeah yeah I
wish to play an instrument that's the
one thing that if I had any like I don't
climb mountains yeah I'm a little lazy i
happen to love standup so that's just by
nature you're lazy um I'm lazy if my
stand-up in the podcast yeah cuz you go
what you do those consistently pres I
[ __ ] love them I yeah to me I think
lazy if there's something you want to do
but it would take a little effort okay
that can get be a little lazy with that
but if you feel physical lazy like going
out and doing stuff cause you look in
good shape you'll have it yeah for a 59
year old guy look hahaha but he called
me old and uh going nowhere earlier well
I'm not gonna it was it with it was
within a bit now I'm paranoid you really
think oh okay no actually I just come I
have people come on and I throw him
under the bus that's the whole that's
all cracks a nice you know it's Mary
throws people under the bus yeah it's
Mary its Mary he'll throw you under that
bus it's Mary it's Mary don't make a big
fuss it's Mary all right I know I'm
isolating that can you put reach a
reverb in that we I've got a whole
system right here we could be in post
yeah I can throw [ __ ] chorus on there a
little bit delay um maybe a flanger but
yeah I do like to go back to you know my
favorite thing I've talked about this is
I'll of to go on the road hang out with
comedians there's nothing better nothing
better excuse me that's why I started
this podcast I wanted to take uh the
[ __ ] we talked about at the bar used to
talk about the bar on thursday nights at
the improv and just throw some mics up
and have a good time begin every time I
do that and I'm like and I'm having one
of those mornings where [ __ ] I don't
want to do this today I don't want to do
this maybe I'll call him a cancel and
then within 10 minutes dude I'm spry I'm
having a good time I'm talking we're
laughing and I'm like me same once in a
blue moon my podcast is literally
besides stand up they're my two favorite
things in the world to do but there are
times when
go on look but once i'm in there i
[ __ ] love it I yeah yeah enough of it
give it the the and you know you asked
me before I like move passengers I
thought it sounded weirdly parsley who
do you invite to the if I do I will
invite um some people sometimes you get
a gist to them you know something thats
hanging out at the show you they came
last year and they gave you something
and you remember them and you know what
I put numbers and everything I've been
ninety-five percent of the time it's
great right five percent of the time
what isn't great it's not a big deal
either maybe someone can't chill or they
can't hang yeah I had a little too much
to drink and you creatively just go
ahead everybody you know but ninety-five
percent of the time overwhelmingly even
some stranger to know and mix them in
with all the comedians um they're great
and they're awesome and it's fun to have
new friends oh yeah no it's like you're
in high school again said you get to
have fun to go back to that market and
see him cuz I've done I've I don't I've
never really invited back to my hotel
room but I've gone out for drinks after
and I'm like Mike Michael cot what's up
you probably listen to this that he came
out to a show in Sacramento and we hung
out had drinks and we've become friends
since so yeah and like you said you
might you we were saying before you
might never see them until you go back
to that city and they always just know
you know maybe this is complimenting
myself but I guess what the [ __ ] right
it seems like if you do if your if your
act it doesn't feed idiots yeah you know
what I mean you could you buy what you
talk about yeah feed you either feed
people that seem to be kind and gentle
and nice and warm they can still like
crass sure sure people can be kind and
gentle and nice and not one [ __ ]
Church comedy right but just the fact
that whoever you're you know verbally
punching you're always like I say
punching the right people I think if you
tend to punch the right people and only
history all right that because i said
this poor everybody does the same thing
everybody just should do what they
[ __ ] want and then you know i do care
that my niece and nephew might listen to
my work after i'm gone and not be
embarrassed yeah with their friends
because that will happen sure that will
happen they will that as weird as that
sounds so anyway you if you feed the
right people they're the ones you get to
meet so
oh but yeah when I meet people like I'm
proud I'm like oh that's what I'm
drawling and if that's who would feel
comfortable at my show you know then
okay maybe that's the reward you get for
trying to do the right thing you know
yeah that's really cool way look and I
never really looked at it that way yeah
certain people they don't directly I
know people that will I know radio
people especially like back in the day
that would complain about their audience
or sometimes you know some of the won't
even mention it but especially radio
audiences and they didn't realize what
they were saying they would be like
otters audiences we did a live remote
those [ __ ] idiots and like oh you
don't think you have anything to do with
that you analytically probably do if I
said you know you have something to
doing that which I never did they'd go
well but they don't realize or do they
wouldn't be saying it because what you
would they're basically saying is oh you
know the audience we draw because a [ __ ]
we do we hate them you know the morons
that listen to me holy yeah boy they say
something progressive and maybe you'll
wipe out a few of those [ __ ] I'm
gonna be less snotty on the road now man
don't talk to the talent I didn't know
nobody comes back to the hotel room I'm
sorry motel room they put me up in now
did you ever like early on did you ever
go out with the audience and this end up
and cuz I learned I learned early on
that you know I could die I don't know
why I'm outside of Spokane 30 minutes
outside of Spokane it is so called
kegger with crystal meth I probably
shouldn't be here you know maybe uh it's
funny you say that because I don't think
I've ever really talked abut that's the
five percent maybe that I'm thought but
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah and you you know
even that is a story Rhino the next day
but yeah we've gone back to people's
house you know or something a lot of
times you get back again it's great
you're like this is so cool them in
someone's house and yeah you know
especially with podcasting in it they
even know you like things so they're
like you want to come back to the house
will have the lights real low light a
fire yeah but um I got a new gel some
weird yeah one night ended up back where
everyone was doing coke right I'm not a
coke person yeah and I remember just
going me and the other comedian we were
like and they couldn't we did one thin
the drive and we couldn't get a cab
so we decide we'll just walk but we was
nothing was going like we will walk to a
gas station will get a cab there and I
guys it's hard to get cabs around here
but we eventually got home we've
actually got home but yeah those those
like not like our early days so early
days you mean like like I started comedy
when I was 16 you started 16 mm-hmm
jealous like I night Wow still yeah but
I did it every week uh I didn't got
stage stand up till 2525 yeah that's
still pretty young I mean I know people
that have even started really yeah i
know people all over the gambit I mean
I'm surprised that I'm still surprising
guys like Brandon Waddell or like you
know who are so young and whit Irma
Thomas guys like right I started really
young but aim Dave Chappelle I think
started at like 16 battle too yeah like
your stories dads having to walk him in
and stuff like that yeah I didn't ever
had all those guys I've heard some of
those guys I mean I've heard that me I
always looked you know I looked I think
when I was 16 I probably look 24 yeah I
always looked a lot older so it's weird
I got in the bars and do not mean I
don't think i don't remember one
situation why do you know you said about
early stories and this I'll just
transfer right over the lovely just
thought of it by you asking me that I
remember one this isn't it someone's
house but I did a one nighter and when I
got there I was just hanging out I went
with my friend who was performing and
then the headliner didn't show up so I
was like I'll go up and then afterwards
the guy didn't want to pay me oh I was
like well I'll deal with the the guy
whoever's name was Paul solari probably
the Booker he goes I'll deal with him
and I was like what and then some guy
comes over to me were outside arguing
but nothing major yeah and the guy comes
over afterwards after World done he goes
come over here can I tell you what you
gotta do you just and he had this accent
yeah you just got it cuz it was like a
bar yeah you know you know how it is you
know not a comedy club this is the bar
goes you got to take a deep breath and
let this go I remember thinking he's
right he goes and you come back here
later with a brick you throw through
that [ __ ] window I'm like all right
this is not you're not not as spiritual
is that thought this guy's gonna lay
some wisdom on me you're [ __ ] burn
this place to it
you take you take a deep breath come
back here you burn this [ __ ]
right why am I using the word
[ __ ] latte when it's saying it
it doesn't bother me I re listened to it
I don't like it you know I'm the same I
say [ __ ] a lot I don't mind saying [ __ ]
doesn't use my mother [ __ ] again why
is the hop in my favorite word yeah and
maybe when it's unnecessary it's
actually socially okay you know it's not
it's not about any group it's just about
I [ __ ] um again doesn't mean what it
used to mean what does [ __ ] used to me
well [ __ ] I think I don't think [ __ ]
unless you're talking about oh he act of
[ __ ] right right right it just means
it's an adjective yeah almost now and
the reason it's an adjective except for
just you might want to give it up just
because grammatically you you want to
sound you know you'd want to sound
intelligent but I'm tillery's and I stay
away from [ __ ] is if I I don't like when
it's creeps into beautiful things like
what a [ __ ] beautiful dama you know
what I don't need it it just sounds
wrong or even in my anger [ __ ]
gorgeous yeah you are dead takes a big
week though that could be like gotchas
[ __ ] amazing shoes you know I know I'm
saying she because I'm so used to well I
could see it beautiful I can see a
beautiful guy right I see when every
time I look in the mirror thank you
hello um yeah I [ __ ] so socially like
I'm yeah I was just talking to a Booker
of a television show and he didn't mind
that I said [ __ ] on my tape I was like
oh I mean I didn't want to give it to
him cuz I'm like you know I said [ __ ] i
was in playing I was like I don't care
yeah your [ __ ] on the late night all the
time now now they just bleep it now they
bleep it yeah it is a great again the
it's it's sometimes it's like look if it
was about like cuz we were talking about
this before we order to show about
different words yeah you know I might
have used at one point and you later you
you're you're genuinely mortified but uh
but that one it's you know it's one we
don't really have to give up because you
know it's just it's not you know it's
not it's not using someone's being is it
yeah if you know but um yeah it's but
again [ __ ] for whatever the
reason like that word is just like hey
use it a lot and you don't like it I
don't like it I don't like it after I
started not necessarily on stage but on
the podcast yeah and when I re listen to
it sometimes I'm like whew you know yeah
we hit what I'm saying you they don't
even I don't I don't think I say
[ __ ] a lot is a [ __ ] a lot but
I'll say [ __ ] a lot you know
initially we talk about words and
learning and stuff it kind of ties to
this is I had somebody and forgive me I
know you're probably listening I said I
would never say your name not like five
people's butts are puckering right now
well yeah I wrote him about this um I
and I won't say your name but and I just
ran over your eamon I'm talking to the
computer like you're like you're there
he's actually making eye contact like
you're like it um but I i'm not against
learning things and we've talked about
words that are offensive and stuff and i
was talking about a joke a friend of
mine did about people with the hair lips
and i got an email from a woman saying
just so you know that's a very offensive
term it was used to I should bring up
the email Rita cuz I'm butchering it
right now and I was like oh my god I had
no idea that the actual term cleft
palate see you know what I'm glad you
brought that up because this is my
never-ending thing talking about this
stuff and I agree with you what is the
crime what I think people a lot of times
they'll hold on to a word because they
didn't mean it with ill intent i like to
say this no one's judging you for using
any word and we don't think there should
be a court order to get you to stop it
everybody should do exactly what they
[ __ ] want right that's the end of
story but that doesn't mean inwardly you
could want to change a word you use and
it does if it doesn't have to have ill
intent I don't think anybody did
anything wrong until someone educates
you so instead of wasting energy going
oh here's why I did it no one's judging
you that you yeah no one's ah but maybe
there are no one no one sane is judging
you for why you did it in the past right
they don't care but going no one's
judging you at all they are if they're
gonna be doing judging judging you for
once information was brought to you
intelligently and kindly and someone
said hey here's how we don't like that
word then I get like wow and they want
to use all their energy
grew up here i use that word no no one
cares yeah want someone in you know
calmly and nicely educated you what's
the big deal to stop using the word you
know what if you decide you're gonna
stop using it eventually it gets out of
your lexicon yeah I'll slip and you'll
say it general I did I did with the word
[ __ ] uh-uh someone explained to me
nicely why I shouldn't use that word I
wasn't offended i wasn't they weren't
being a bully that is being nice and
kind and if it and if it's cuz someone
asked me this once they go I'm always
afraid when I slip and say it or people
judging me I go look I don't know what
people are doing but I can tell you what
I hear if I'm in the if I'm here
somebody in another room and they're
saying so anyway it was just so stupid
it was [ __ ] and they went excuse me
clumsy right I go we know what I think
is in the other room an intelligent
person yeah going through that period I
don't go Oh know if they were the
ultimate of it they would know I think
oh that's so it's just if you wanted out
of your lexicon and you give half a [ __ ]
about it right it'll come out it takes
maybe maybe half a year and then
eventually you know you go I've not
using that word anymore I never heard
that about hair lift so neither did I
and so yeah and I wish in I should again
i'm an idiot cuz i've done the several
times to talk about somebody's email i
could probably get it but i'm not but
again it might do the same thing of the
show we go we have a computer right yeah
yeah we're like what was that what year
was that do you think yeah why don't we
just do a search yeah that's so fun like
my what my wife is in all my listeners
know i love her more than anything in
the world but she is all what she's one
of those people like phones are killing
us the computer is the dude cell phones
are killing us everybody is on and i was
at the beach the other day and none of
us had our phones and you know how our
conversation wit dude remember that
movie in 83 the one with uh Christ you
know the guy who was in the deer hunter
didn't you're not to Nero then when you
try to think of you some of the
healthier you don't know that either
you're like you can't think of the
actress then you go okay who what was
the move and then year then you're just
going down for more there's a commercial
for Volkswagen he did in night 45
minutes of that was our conversation
without our phones if we had her phone
it would have been home
and you know what you know sometimes I
wonder like why I talk about the same
thing over and over again and I think
because it comes up in directly over and
over again and the thing with the cell
phone right I don't know why it's so
important me every time I hear that to
sort of give my stance on it maybe
because i think i can change people's
behavior but i always say if you just
use some social stats whatever you think
is killing the generation it never was
like we're we when's the last time you
heard a story about all the dumb kids in
the fifties that all they did was sit
around and watch TV cuz that's what that
the older generation when's the last
time you heard you while you the ear of
books were they ruined everybody cuz
people will just so in a fantasy so a
good way to find out if what you think
is going to be the legacy of the you
know like on the phones it it never has
in the past right it's probably what
happens is not that that's not a part of
it and not that i have friends and the
bad part about cell phones and there is
an it is a little easier to be
distracted or oh but you're in control
over it so if you make some rules with
most of your friends all my close
friends we have cell phone rules and no
one gets mad if you're going if someone
reminds me because I'm the sort of the
king of it but I need to be reminded
sometimes when someone has to remind me
they think I'm gonna puff up a little
bit they're like odd I know but I go no
no thank you thank you have not even
doing anything important i'm scrolling
through we don't mind and we set some
good rules so the negative part about
cell phones are in your control but i
think what's gonna super supersede the
UM again yeah I get it it's annoying you
get into an elevator i remember now put
it down yeah i know someone don't talk
through the line at the grocery store
but these are all controllable things i
don't think that's how history is gonna
write itself it's gonna be the knowledge
and the intelligence in the and the
things it brought to people right and
it's like a knife it's like let's get
rid of knives i mean they stab people
how the [ __ ] is just gonna be an
argument yeah knives kill people and
then you go they operate on people you
go all those guards tip in this mail and
i think that's how cell phones are yeah
it's not because i say the same thing
whenever my wife would go down that path
I go oh man they said the same thing
about the horseless carriage this is
dope this is the death of all of us they
do and you know i just heard books i
never knew that like I love being locked
and loaded with examples yeah someone to
I go books hell to me though
they go yeah because not books maybe
with knowledge you know like we're right
but it was like science fiction or or
you know or you know probably because of
the storytelling aspect of it is that I
thought it would get people lost in this
someone just told me this a week ago
probably not doing a good job of but it
was the same thing with books it was
like oh they're gonna be the end of us
you know people probably were sitting
around reading book yeah now we don't
read enough even my wife tells me we
already enough does she read a lot she's
a big reader um you know it's very funny
and I won't say who said this
observation because it beats out like
his name dropping Dennis Quaid um I
don't know Zweifel Dennis quite out of
my ass I could yeah I couldn't think of
George Clooney's name and I came up
attended anyway they said he's like
remember when there were phone booths
and if you were to like even touch the
doorknob of a phone booth with hey whoa
privacy privacy I'm in here what's up
what are you doing what are you doing
dude this guy's try I'm trying to talk
here get some privacy now everybody's on
the phone my wife had her second
abortion and it's it's just a complete
turnaround yeah and even though like
again like I think if you defend phones
people think Oh doesn't he said no no
hey believe me the phone not even
yelling like let's say yelling on a
scale from one to ten on yourself
intends yelling like what are you you
know to me the category that I deal with
more than that is the 10 is yelling 10
is like okay that guy's the girls got a
problem right but the fives and sixes
like yeah you're not yelling but still I
shouldn't be able to hear your
conversation uh but begin that's all
controllable I'm manually aware of that
that's why I don't never wanted the
Bluetooth because you don't have to yell
for a Bluetooth and we have to talk at a
normal volume and sometimes the norva
normal volume is too loud yeah so with
the earpiece you can pull it you know
you take it you pull it over to your
mouth and you go hey uh yeah I'm on the
treadmill but can I call you back in 20
minutes you know right anyways I just
show and I feel like I'm leading off to
just know nobody likes me I meant like
you know I don't want to like go up in
these pages that's all that's all my
show is tangents thanks for listening to
it beforehand though oh yeah
I want to adopt some cell phone rules I
think that's a good idea now do you how
do you feel that I mean how have you
obviously had to deal with cell phones
in audiences I said how I bring it
around back to my show I know I like I'm
an expert I'm a PI I have a way I deal
with that I think I get rid of almost
all of it to the the I the majority of
the time really and what I do is I do my
own announcement at clubs so you know
it's if I'm working a new club I always
say you know call them on the phone go
here's some things I like to do if
you're okay with that I are great things
about your club most of the club's I've
been to and I make my own announcement
you know when it's five minutes before
show time yeah and I don't think you can
get rid of that stuff by gun ladies and
gentlemen good evening and welcome to
the thing remember to turn your cell
phones off and please no texting during
the show keep I go I go hey everybody uh
as I think as years have evolved that
people might know it's me I go hey
everybody it's Todd right on I wanted to
start the show from the back it since
it's a two-person show and there's no
host tonight I thought I would just come
on and welcome you all here and I go
listen when it comes to the cell phones
there's no fast way to do this where
it's gonna stick in your head I go I
promise you I get it it's tempting even
the texting sometimes you think I'm just
one person in 300 but we look out and we
see 50 people so I promise you if you
turn yourself off from the outside world
will throw that love right back at you
and I do need to be honest with you
affectionately there will be people that
still pull out their cell phones all I
can tell you now all eyes will go to you
right if you're pulling it out you're
putting it near your knee all eyes will
go to you and you will look like a dick
and it gets rid of the majority really
yeah mm-hmm that's amazing of the
majority of it and I'm and I and because
yet is hard it is hard to look out there
and see them on there oh yeah I'm gonna
adopt that man I think that's a it works
everyone's a good idea you have to
explain to them wide so yeah doctor used
to tell me to floss but he didn't tell
me why I had a de flaw so you're just
are you flossing you flossing but if you
tell people why to get off their phones
and you educate them oh yeah they see 50
of us right um so I think I think you
just it does work even with the heckling
I deal with that I go let me explain
something you know a lot of people one
of the biggest misconceptions with no
sarcasm at all huh and sometimes I'll
even break and I'll go hey by the way I
want to make sure you
all know this announcement is not meant
to be disrespectful if it comes off that
way genuinely it's not right I wouldn't
rip through this if I didn't have an
amazing amount of respect for the crowd
and I want this to be special yeah so
it's worth taking a minute to make it
special I go um but uh some people
thought yelling outs part of the show
they really did they've never been no
calming them I should let you know now
it's not right and um I stole a line
from the punchline in San Francisco i
love it i go and i should let you know
and I don't make the rules here at the
club they don't have a warning policy at
this club which I can't say it bothers
me I sort of like it but we should let
you know if you hack will once they just
have to ask you to leave the showroom
there's no warning it's just you heckle
you leave right so I think that would be
good and the only reason we've done that
is because that's how our customers have
wanted it that the or I say then but
yeah punch line did it that way they go
and we only reason we do that because
that's why if customers have wanted it
since we opened our doors in 1982 I love
that it's like yeah it's not us we don't
give a [ __ ] our customers don't want to
hear you yell right a [ __ ] up Wow is the
reason you have a two man shows because
you're opening speeches 30 minutes ever
it gets you know what it gets so longer
but I need to grow them under the bus
gets longer it does sometimes I think
god its skin I try to keep it it ends up
being three minutes right but it gets a
laugh or so in there I do something but
it tell you what when i send the middle
guy up there I love this majority of the
time they come to me they're like wow
I've never been handed an audience that
civil before wow you know and I put my I
put time between that message and then
bringing up the first day and I'm all
done i go other than that folks we're
glad you're here i don't want to say are
you in a good mood or anything real
we're glad you're here i go by the
sounds of it it sounds like everybody's
in good spirits and guess what it's show
time real salt and then the two piece
band or pre-recorded music boom ba ba ba
ba ba ba ba for like 20 seconds boom
black out ladies and gentlemen chip
Chantry mover back he walks to the mic
starts telling his jokes not how you
doin just boom that walks to that monk
like a like Bobby miyamoto some of the
guys I used on the right I love Bobby's
a guy Bobby does agrees he's amazing
because I like the guys I set it up I
will get that crowd there will be no
talking I'll start the show 10 minutes
late I'll tell the club if it means
drinks
maybe they're coming in late I will hand
you the most civil audience all I need
you to do is go to that Mike do whatever
you do if it's calm I don't want just
walked into my start telling jokes hmm
awesome you know and it works I love the
idea of just explaining it to them you
know I mean and I try to think I try and
I try to keep that in my mind too
because I remember I grew up skiing your
Pennsylvania guy right and I grew up see
so where do we go where'd you grow up
primarily New Jersey so Jersey a little
town near wayne your Wayne New Jersey
away New Jersey well I lived in Wayne
Pennsylvania so easy oh yeah there's a
way in paia where's that west west side
you're like valley forge area mainline
king of prussia paoli or win or all your
philadelphia people okay keep going I'm
pressure see nothin where Villanova
compression that wind Lafayette hills
fort meyers sara wawa around there's our
oh god don't get no no have you ever
been to a wall I know why I have a lot
of my family lives in the Philadelphia
wait I interrupted you you were gonna
say something about oh just explaining
then that like that makes so much sense
and I remember growing up skiing when I
was somebody's teaching me how to ski
the the minute they said you put your
pressure on your right foot to turn left
because it bends the ski and that causes
you to turn I know how to ski you know
what I've let's I figured out why why am
i why i had to do but if you don't
understand the mechanism I didn't know
why I had to put my right foot and why
is my right foot turning me left and all
but once somebody said oh that's how it
works I know how to skate and then it
just all clicked I think that's a good
analogy and I think it does work and I
figured it out just years in like you
know like just an honest announcement no
music ya know blaring music just clean
voice you ladies and gentlemen we have
your attention you got a lovely voice oh
thank you ladies and gentlemen uh and I
and I like it I like setting up a civil
of in the audience be civil Todd glass
were I can honestly say probably worked
every improv in the country every
thursday through sunday for four years
whether he was there and out
right because you had the opening video
you know the old one which they don't
know if you've never been doing improv
there's an opening video and they don't
play it anymore the old one was better
okay and there's a new one with me and
Jim Breuer and that's one like I need to
what that's the one that they are they
still playing that cuz I don't even well
some play there Jim Breuer one has
something to do with Jim it just by love
Jim but it has to do with the first one
was I did it a long time ago and was a
manager the improv I loved that he
wanted to do that he goes I do like a
bit quiet thing it has guts yeah it says
yeah you're in a restaurant also but
it's a comedy club first and it's not
the customer's always right we have to
lovingly but sternly say that you know
and uh your wallet it's in my head oh
really did you one night at the Dallas
improv every waiter and waitress they
had it planned adopt wherever they rat
and set it along with haha and I melted
it was so overwhelming just because they
hear it all the track that they did it
made me but it's like everybody want to
welcome to the improv you know some
people were walking by the improv they
go hey let's go to the improv but three
people don't want to go to people to go
so they talk during the show then the
manager comes over is hey could you
please keep it down to go we were just
laughing stop it already talking about a
joke 20 minutes after the comedian told
isn't just laughing if you were laughing
of course we're not crazy that's what we
love don't say but my uncle's the mayor
my sister owns Chicago we don't give a
[ __ ] you're come in here there's good
quality comedy not that many things in
life are that complicated laughs shut up
laughs shut up now if you're thinking
wow that's no way to start a show that's
cuz you were gonna talk we don't give a
[ __ ] boom music kicks in which one had
the greatest line to lose either that
one or the one with Brewer where you're
like nobody has ever been kicked out of
a comedy club for laughing about right
we were just laughing you know you
worked I even just brought that back to
my pre-announcement ignora you know what
I'm serious and again I'll move past
this but no I love it I I learned the
more you tell them the truth and I say
folks if you think this has been a wordy
announcement up to now this is the last
thing but it's wordee there's just no
way to say it ladies and gentlemen don't
forget I do that literally and i go i
can tell you when there's people
heckling the door staff is not afraid to
go over because people inherently no
that's wrong right but when people are
just
ki it's not yelling just talking the
door staff i'm being genuine is scared
to go over they've seen how annoyed
people get somewhat civil people it
brings a heart quants you nobody wants
to go over so in the event if you're a
good nice person maybe add a few drinks
and one of our staff has to come over it
doesn't have to be the end of your night
you don't have to shut up and pal they
don't want you too pal right so if
there's nothing to be quiet just smile
back and go okay thank you man that ends
that [ __ ] the doorman tell me they
go you know what it really does end that
because you know what every people don't
realize when you tell someone to be
quiet the door staff goes back to their
station and stares at the table because
it's fun because you watch a full grown
adult route right oh I won't heckle and
I won't talk but they can't believe it
happened to them like if you showed
someone a video of that person's
reaction and goes was this person just
told to please be quiet in a soft tone
or shut the [ __ ] up you pile a shake at
the [ __ ] out of my restaurant which did
they say I guarantee you if 20 by
watching this guy's reaction he wasn't
told to please be quiet I'll tonight hey
he was told to shut me be like no he was
told them the look on their faces like
what the [ __ ] be quiet and then they get
to the door staff they get to the
manager when I was a doorman at a comedy
club I same thing I told people I had
even my own tricks i will go over and go
listen I go last night we had a lot of
trouble with some hecklers probably were
a little overreacting what can you just
keep it down right he went to the
manager and he said he I was told him to
shut the [ __ ] up and I member Steve
Young this is when I was like 19 years
old he goes let me tell you something my
employees make mistakes so believe me
they make mistakes right but if you want
to start all over again they might have
made a mistake but if you don't want to
reconsider that they told you to shut
the [ __ ] up we're done he goes ito
because what happens is i think by the
time they get to the manager it's very
hard because there may be some
intelligence deep down to go over and go
excuse me one of your door staff came
over they leaned down and they asked me
to please be quiet so they realized that
that doesn't sound bad so the guy goes
he told me to shut the [ __ ] up and Steve
Jones I remembered he goes I'm done with
you well happen I can't have a
discussion here that I
no is based on not the truth they didn't
if you said tone I could go with they
didn't tell you to shut the [ __ ] up and
that's what I always think of like when
they go you told me to shut the [ __ ] up
no no no I did yeah well I didn't know
you're a doorman where are you door mana
at the comedy works in philly oh yeah
yeah you just got her a new comedian
like you know you do comedy and then you
like work at the club yeah I did that
it's a store you did that at least yeah
i got started out here so I dorm and at
the store how many years I got fired
within the year why did you fire cuz
it's the [ __ ] comedy store somebody
just got shot and killed there the place
is this horrible horrible place somebody
asked me where it happened and I was
like it could happen anywhere it but but
this takes a turn I you knowing that
that tragedy happen I go first well
let's make something very very clear it
could happen anywhere oh yeah anywhere
anywhere but you want me to guess the
comedy Stewart right Yes No go and the
door managed to sell coke that's just
put it right there but uh but yeah yeah
I worked at the club for a while did
help did that one did that help you you
know I looked out I started a club in
Philadelphia just gone God is gone and
and I was 16 when I started doing
stand-up and then about a year after
that after i graduated or a year and a
half i started working there doing the
door whatever door sound you just yeah
you did whatever you had to do and i'm
the owner had great taste in comedy and
i think it taught me a lot like
literally the guys i would see uh of
course i'm mentioning the ones that have
gone on to you know dreams but I
remember I remember people very well
that did not go on to be successful
there were hilarious to there and what
they're in my comedy heart too but like
who guys like you know guys like um uh
you know Steve Steve Shaffer then you
know isn't a household name right guys
like uh Glenn Hirsch or you know not
everybody knows carol leifer right
comedians all know care yeah but like
you know the really funny people but the
but like everybody from like Jay Leno
Jerry Seinfeld they were already pretty
big acts you know uh Garry Shandling you
know Gilbert Godfrey steven wright Paul
Reiser so I would get to see some
great comedian yes and uh Jeff to heart
was a comedian that I remember um todd
todd gets a genuine smile on his face
when he when he says those names well
cuz i won't want to just remember the
ones that are that have gone on to be
famous it seems like but uh so i saw a
great comedy and you know the so i did I
learned a lot the owner that club man
Steve Young he was he was he loved
stand-up comedy and he was really
supportive i perceived and to me was
really supportive you know that's great
comedians yeah that's great uh yeah
Mitzi really wasn't no I did I did write
Mitzi shoot Mitzi shore is the owner of
The Comedy Store Pauly Shores mother and
I will speak nice of the soon-to-be dead
because she's that sounded crass I meant
that legitimately nice because she's old
and on her way out so I'll speak kindly
of her but um I to drive her they had a
death trap of a limo that you had to
drive Mitzi around and I had to go pick
her up at the La Jolla Comedy Store
which all be next weekend hit me up our
tickets because it yeah wait so you
drove from San Diego all the way here I
drove from here to San Diego to pick her
up to come back in this death trap of a
limo oh god I just love the image of
that like her in there like royalty you
think but think about you know what was
last nobody really has limos anymore
they're all suvs but it's it's a little
much for looks like a 78 limo to show
it's not it has that like weird wing in
the back sticking up the I don't some
sort of int and I guess I don't know it
oh the head for the phone wait like it
looked like you said a wing in the back
a is for the phone it was for the money
yeah yeah an antenna and had like a
mirrored kind of thing or and it just
shook it like 72 get to get to get to
get to get to get and Iran would kind of
picked her up she did she's like we're
going to sell she talks we're going to
the steakhouse for dinner I'm like okay
she's like you turak take the exit off
oh I'm out for miles where does that
mean you to me too it was gonna be me
and her at dinner but I like okay Mitzy
I gotta pull over and get gas no I want
to go to the steakhouse like okay Mitzy
but I just gotta blow our money I just
gotta know we'll get it out
his take out so like all right I'm a
young kid I don't know ten minutes later
the diktat just dead on the 405 yes not
take responsibility go how could you
pick me up so low on gas am i right oh
yeah oh yes I'd to leave her in the bed
she like why why are we out of gas I'm
like Mitzi cuz we just ran out of gas
he's like oh and it's like Sunday
afternoon or something and I'd get out
and walk cuz I didn't have a cell phone
you know who's like to get out walk to
the gas station go get gas in a thing
come back fill it up fill back a picker
up drive back she's just cussing me out
for an hour and a half fun of why you
[ __ ] gay gay did you eat your steak
what no we can't get the steak dinner we
missed the steak dinner didn't even get
the steak there I'm famished hey pull
into the comedy store everybody's got
their nose up her butt in that place man
and there is like Oh Mitzi oh I'm so
sorry I'm so you had to go through that
I'm like I'm gonna had to hike five
miles cuz she wanted to steak dinner
nothing no nothing over here for me
anyway he fired oh really yeah you know
I've been going over to the store a
little bit lately and you know i do like
I've had some really fun nights and hold
on I've I felt I didn't mean the way
that came out about talking till about
I'm just saying I'm just saying she's
very sick and she's gonna be gone soon
and I don't want to I said the same
thing about the gunshot so like how you
know I know it you know I say like well
but like I I just don't go over there
that often even though when I go over
there you know it has had an image over
the years of a more of a gruff place but
I feel like all the newer comedians it's
almost adorable or endearing maybe it's
a better word that they don't want it to
be that way so and I feel like when I go
over there they're so kind and so sweet
like fri so embracing um so some nights
i like to go to the store I treat it
like going into the city like it's a
different I don't do it all the time it
feels different you can pop around the
different rooms i love to smoke pot you
can go upstairs the valley rumor it's
it's it hey by the way if i had money
like you know like anybody who has money
like you know but whoever i can never
think it was mr. money pants i would
want to buy that place in a heartbeat
because i think the soul and the idea of
three rooms i would just make some
changes yeah yeah but uh I i would i
would think i would i would want to do
that because it just it just needs like
it I wouldn't take off i need those
pictures on the walls are
he writes all of it you know yeah it
needs like a you know a little bit of a
whitewash yeah I never started rugs out
of there but they would still have smell
better yeah I sir I started going back
there again and it was funny i even had
listeners come out the night i went back
because they knew i was i always said
I'd never stepped foot in that place
again and then the night i went back
like five listeners were like they're
like we're of course we're coming back
were you we want to see this and then
it's like I had a good time that night
and then I went back again and it was
like the same old place that I left and
then I so I don't know I go back and
forth on it but I'm guys I respect i
know im an improv guy that's me i love
the energy down there that doorman or
like it just it just even though with
all the changes over the years and some
you know they move the bar there right
you have to get over it otherwise you're
just a guy walks into the improv and
tells everyone how great it used to be
guess what younger people don't give a
full right right so i just make new what
we're not having a good time right now
so we're having a lot of time yeah i
thought we were having a good i guess
i'm sorry i guess not so you get over it
and you make new memories and um and but
i love the improv the door staff that's
just a great energy down there i will
say this man uh when I want to record my
album that came out this year I I wanted
to do it in town i contacted three
different clubs the one I got started at
gave me [ __ ] but the improv was like oh
really want to do it at our club here's
this state to state the state the state
pick whichever one you want you they
promoted my show probably more than any
other club has promoted me ever they had
a huge banner out on the you know
recording live here and you know on the
date or whatever its without there for a
month and stay on one of my favorite
clubs yeah me too and there's a reason
why there's so many of them and they're
so professional and I say this many
times of this i remember i was i think i
was working ontario irvine and four guys
rolled up and were just hammered and the
door and I stalking the manager and the
doorman chem sup he's like a man we got
four guys who are obviously too drunk in
the manager reaches in his pocket
because before free passes says hey say
uh you know apologize say you've had a
little bit too much to drink tonight
here's for free passes come back next
week of what a way to handle that man
instead of let's put them in the front
row because they're gonna buy more
drinks yeah that's store i always tell
about the DC improv same thing yeah you
will never hear someone go you know that
first that table in the first
was obnoxious you'll never hear a door
mango I know I've dealt with him in line
because they wouldn't get to the first
right some clubs they do yeah of course
it a plan implemented but anyway we're
there a ton of one-nighters nailed in
the philly area when you started there
were i never really went on the road any
because at that time there were five or
six clubs right this is road stories
dead this is Road story soon well I know
I do have have one nighters they were
all around Philadelphia the first the
first paid job ever got was to go to it
was with Wayne Federman oh yeah first
paid like road job really I went to the
DC improv did you know Wayne ahead of
time her I didn't know way nice are you
met Wayne would say that again this is
where you met Wayne this is my wet Wayne
Malloy say Wayne Federman yeah yeah okay
oh I met Wayne Federman uh was at a club
in washington DC called the comedy yet
not connection comedy i forget the cafe
mm-hmm and it was above a strip joint
that the owner owned he owned both he
owned the strip joint with what's called
I think Archer balls and then upstairs
was the comedy club a pretty cool little
comedy club what type nicely run I think
it was called our Archibald's why is
that a funny that's a funny for a strip
club god I wonder if I'm right I think
it's hilarious only if we had a way to
find that out well wonder if you could
hold on Elaine move my computer all the
way would you say I said I think it was
Archie oh I don't know huh and the owner
hallway and later dropped the mic and
don't talk about the strippers so of
course I thought it was funny to drop
the mic and go hope the strippers didn't
hear it and he yelled at me after the
show so much that I started to cry oh
really like I hold it back a little sure
sure I'd too and then I felt worse
because he saw that I was getting a
little bit teary-eyed and he felt bad
but I'm watching a guy who does not know
how to really so now I feel bad for him
because I you know I'm where he feels
horrible right right how to show it but
I was so like I've never been yelled at
like that before so I was like started
to choke up then I just follow the rules
the rest of the week do anything wrong
but um yeah that was that was comedy
cafe in DC and that's the first time I
ever drank oh really drank once before
that once before is you're like what 18
at this point maybe yeah it could be 18
yeah 18 so I never really dry
before maybe one time before that with
my friend with two of my friends that I
worked at with dairy queen at but uh
that was it and then I got so drunk at a
place in downtown what's that college
town near DC everybody go Georgetown so
I went down there and got drunk with
another comedian and oh my god other
like just uh and then I'm but that was
like crazy back then you know do you
know you know your hotel and you're
doing shows yeah Wayne was a super nice
guy and why is awesome yeah we've always
been loves Archibald I hear he just
can't get enough art what a weird name
for a strip club I really want to find
out that I'm almost positive I believe
you but I just think they put down
stairs so much thought into the comedy
cafe alliteration and are all this we
got Archibald or what was that what was
the comedian who passed away uh you'll
know as soon as I say just notorious
partier strippers not Sam Kinison no no
no no he wasn't really he was really who
was he kinnison's open now he wasn't
part of the outlaws what's his name John
Fox remember John Fox yeah John Fox ears
like John Fox oh that's in the I am
comic isn't John Fox the one that would
like there's no tourist stories about he
would like masturbating to the don't
know why miss old I was like a mom
uh-huh turn down the volume for a minute
I don't want to see her go yeah he's
into the ice trays see how are the
mayonnaise jar whatever yes something
yeah that's a guy oh anyway he had a
joke about Archibald something or other
he was notorious for I don't know why I
thought of that I will say this he's the
only person I've ever seen who a
stripper brought him drugs to the club
who like like what year what where is
this where is this was
I don't know not of 2,000 who was after
I came back so I'm still doing a lot of
feature work so it was 2008 I didn't
even know he died he died two years ago
get like he like stage 4 colon cancer or
something but he's not like he talked to
me him in the MC talked me to go into a
strip club with him and uh I don't
really i'm not a huge strip club fan and
I know Oh everybody said but I'm not
then I went there in the stripper's like
John we heard we heard your comment and
pulled out a bag of marijuana Brett pot
brownies and cookies like here we bake
these for you and everything that might
even the last time it's a guy who goes
to a strip club a lot i might even the
last time I've ingested marijuana no I
think about it I didn't start I started
on the probably on the road about when I
was 30 yeah smoking pot until then can
you smoke pot before you on stage good
question oh thank you I I overwhelmingly
don't uh uh but it has worked okay it
has worked and done a lot of good things
you know I think George Carlin once said
use it as a reward so what I try to do
is think all right that did that that
loosened you up you took the bit longer
now do it without pot don't just be able
to do it with pot okay and that will
happen i'll do the same joke the next
night to go member with on your pot it
took your guard down a little got your
filter down a little the problem is that
if i do it i forget my material a lot
uh-huh so what I try to do is like the
best place it ever worked out they just
happen to have a music stand it the
because the stool is there but it's you
know you have to maybe pick the P the
music stain you know you get it right
where you want it you tilt that sure and
then I had a watch that I taped onto it
so I could see my material if I need a
big black sharpie not written in pencil
where had to pick it up nice clean notes
on two pieces of printing paper the
watch I know how time I have then I
could really love it yeah I can really
love it but over well i would say
majority time I don't write road now in
town doing 10-minute spots a lot yeah
but on the road when I have to do an
hour and this comes from a
non-judgmental I judge not in so I wish
I can't smoke pot anymore he smoked pot
in college high school loved it
I don't know I went straight edge for
like six years like no drinking no drugs
nothing like that and when I came back
age was so powerful I I take one hit I
laughed for a half hour and then I cry
and wonder what I'm doing with my life
it's not it's not fun everybody has a
different experience I've been around
people that come on you I go no it
doesn't do somebody right man do them
right but it does for me still I went
through one period where um my ex is in
turn was living in turn yeah okay was
living here living here in my house for
six months he needed a place to live
anyway was your ex here also her we had
already cracking up and but he's but
we're still very amicable and he needed
a places I tell you this for a reason so
any rob was not 21 years old I hope so
what I hope you're telling it is for a
reason yes why just um and he smoked pot
you know he's 21 years old but seven
days a week sure and I started smoking
pot six seven days a week and stopped
enjoying it that was like two years ago
and now I'm back to what I normally do
yeah probably it's still a decent amount
yeah but it's it's I think if it's the
reason it still works for me it still
gets out of your system so when I smoke
I feel it so you know I'll smoke like
four nights a week that's a that's a
nice amount of pot smoking there like
once a month at four or five times a
week um but uh it seems to work for me
and I still I love it I've i would love
to smoke pot I cuz to me like coming
home the kids asleep throw on a movie
burn one chill go to bed that sounds
like an awesome night that just sounds
like a good nice relaxing night from a
stressful day I do drink here's and
again I don't want to sound like one of
those people that you know it's like
trying to get you to like you know then
nobody needs vices if they don't they're
right right can you stop with my arm
twisting please thank you i preach but
your arm back in your pocket thank you
did you ever think like maybe unless I
could sorry it's the worst impression of
a bong ever let me see if I can do a
better what I had actual real water I
can't do it I had so you
from the the weed you made me smoke
before this so I maybe have you maybe
you're smoking did you ever think of
giving it a shot where you just take a
little like a little puff well here's
the problem when I did it again and I
had a roommate who was a total waken
Baker and I shouldn't have smoked his
you know what I mean like why if I'm
gonna because it was so strong yeah if
I'm gonna start racing cars maybe not
start off with Mario Andretti maybe yeah
maybe work my way up and I think that's
what I did and it just [ __ ] do just
it just it doesn't work for me the show
being road store is this would be
apropos when I was in Houston I did the
owner his wife made a bachelor cuz i
said i never had pot brownies mhm hot
cookies bought whatever she made me a
batch uh like six or seven pot cookies
and I had told mark I said I said how
many should I have or he goes will yes
me know how often I smoke pot at that
point it could have been once a week
right yeah he goes you know what have a
half of a half because you know you can
always take more but it's but no one
told me it's slow acting no one told I
always tell people nobody told me it was
a body high I had to literally go it was
like my body they're like oh it's a body
high oh and no one so anyway I start
eating half a one thing a quarter
nothing by the time I had a whole one I
did feel it about 35 minutes later right
and I was aware enough to know this is
it the Houston lab stuff I was
self-aware enough to know don't eat
those cookies to now please your
appetite because there's more pot in
there right hey and I had 30 and I woke
up I remember laying in bed it felt good
mmm it was weird but I was like little
like if elucidating was on a scale from
one to ten ten being crazy 02 okay but
there was definitely you know I would
look at an image and I would take that
image and triple it off sure sure and
then I could blink my eyes and even
shake it out you know it's very but um
so the next day he picks me up for radio
it's like you know whatever seven in the
morning yeah and I'm so out of it that I
forget he's the one that gave me I
thought it looked unprofessional you
know you're young you don't want to look
like you know show you your high picking
up for radio so you write whatever the
reason that doesn't you know I'm sure
he's dealing with comedians but um so
he's used to it but we go through the
McDonald's drive-thru and I don't say
anything
he goes help you know to get some egg
mcmuffin i can tell you my logic behind
it normally I don't want one egg
mcmuffin I want to mmm I've gotten three
halfway through the third one I'm now
throw it out so two and a half I can eat
two and a half it's easy so I said for
because to me two and a half is when I'm
not high whatever [ __ ] is in me now I
want so when he goes for years for he
goes how many of those pot cookies did
you eat I go oh my god mark I'm freaking
out i forgot that he was the one that
gave him to me anymore and i told him
he's like whoa so we you know he felt
really bad I owe me house you know that
he didn't tell me need four of them and
then I went and did radio and he told
them that I was he'd had to tell them oh
really yeah because I was really in your
own head now where I was ooh just just
feeling like it was crazy I can't even
explain it but it was like it wasn't bad
i was just this the body high yeah the
body what's a body high it's like your
legs are warm uh-huh your arms are warm
a heaviness but not a bad happiness if
that makes any sense that's what I
experienced and on the radio I kept
saying or wheel in the air and they're
like yes and then like the fifth time I
go we on there they go you serious I go
I got you but I did you know I was like
I was still but that was uh that was um
yeah that was the first time I ever did
pop brownies on the road have you read
anything thrown at you on stage wow
that's a good question too I've never
been asked that and yes I ask a lot of
questions um I'm s2 I am one situation
where have thrown on me where eight uh a
girl took a piece of straw it's not a
big big thing you anything and she
afflicted at me you know she went like
this and it's very I sulting it's like
you're some piece of [ __ ] yeah and
especially the flick yeah it's like she
went like that like if you know it just
it just brushed my shirt or something
and then I went okay is that not a big
deal and I went back and I did it to her
I said let me show and the guy got so
furious and I remember thinking God if
you were half intelligent you'd use that
opportunity go yeah we don't care
right it doesn't matter just say he's
proving my point but it was just the
flick of the it was a flick of the just
a straw at me and the only other thing
now that was that one other time
somebody was being so rude in the first
row and it was like a one night or not a
club where they would have dealt with it
and I took a drink I took my bottle of
water and I went oh do it there's no
civil so there's no civility here so you
don't know what's right or wrong so I
guess you wouldn't know when it's on
mind either and then we can all get
along but you're not one of those people
if I do something wrong then all of a
sudden you know right from all right oh
please please just at least be some of
you have no [ __ ] idea that way i can
do [ __ ] to you you can do [ __ ] to me
anyone [ __ ] enough so I poured water in
a jacket she got so mad and that I ended
up bringing me to court what now this
was like you know a long time ago so I
don't remember exactly what it was but
it was on like gate like if you littered
yeah it was some saipa fine like that
public did after I forget what it was
brand went to court and you know her her
brother cut our lawn like he had a lawn
service any way through it all he was
still friends with me I'm talking then
that we were gonna go to court he was
cutting lawn he said what do you think
is gonna happen I go and I told me cuz I
think you're gonna lose only because
it's sort of your job to handle that but
my sister you know he was we were civil
about let's go so I went in the court
and uh the judge basically at one point
she kept saying all I did this is a
great judge I couldn't believe it he
goes she kept saying all I did was talk
he goes whoa i use i'm not i haven't
made a decision on this and we're in
small claims court no one's going to
jail he goes but don't when you keep
saying all you did was talk it's not
like he is a carpenter and as you talk
he can keep doing his work you're
stopping him from his job so let's at
least call for what it is you're
stopping him from working let's just
call it that because you are Wow and and
then she would go on and on and then he
goes well again I was like who the [ __ ]
is this judge to be a stand-up comedian
and this part I think am I making this
up like when I've told this story huh
this next part ago but he did he goes
maybe he didn't have it but he goes
listen I know what it's like I sit
behind this
bench and I have the law behind me and I
know what it's like when people are
disrespectful and talking he was in I
have the law behind me and then when I
don't have the law behind me he said
something like a joke i guess i also
have his bat right i was like wow and
then and then my friend chris kosha got
up to defend me and he goes in all
fairness i made my decision of my friend
Chris goes oh it's such a good thing
Randy yeah and he just he decided you
know with you he said he offered to pay
your dry cleaning already okay well now
and she just can't and then he said no
now now whatever it is he just dismissed
it and then she was what can he still
paying my dry cleaning [ __ ] know he
offered to do that up front now not
dragging him here no you pay your own
dry cleaning and next time you go to a
club he didn't oh that's what he did say
just for what it's worth he didn't think
I returned any uh behavior that was more
egregious than hers because yes if he
would have spit on you or if you would
have punched you but he threw water on
your jacket you admitted that you know
you were yelling outside you me cuz
something I said asked her questions she
went oh I'm a [ __ ] everybody I'm a
[ __ ] thinking that's where I was gonna
go which I wasn't right anyway was that
that story was so was my wife in the
club so I feel like that story was
horrible that's right that was a
horrible call back to you calling my
wife a [ __ ] I didn't which I don't know
if you did that on there Oh God oh it
before we put on the is do I go just so
your listeners I go I go just I don't
know that much you know we don't know
that much about each other right I go is
he asked Mary I go oh do you have any is
your wife of any kids from a previous
marriage just learning and he goes what
do you say my wife's a [ __ ] so you know
what a lot of people can call back jokes
that work I didn't like all that jokes
they heard they heard yeah I call that
jokes by the way that's the other thing
I've done when I've drank too much on
stage if I have five drinks or under
just from proven from my record my show
will be absolutely fine right does the
safe six-drink make it horrible maybe
not but it's when it starts creeping
into that shower ettore and I would do
callbacks to jokes I didn't do and the
worst is when i went to call backs to
Bobby Miyamoto's jokes that he didn't do
because sometimes have I know I know
again I'll go out on stage and I'll be
like hey folks how about a hand for
Bobby ball sack because he is a joke
about and then I know laughs at all I
goat Bobby did you do that's hilarious
well it's funny I'm thinking I i just
stumbled across Todd glass set on
Showtime or something and he doesn't
remember doing it uh but he looked very
nice wait you just recently yeah yeah I
told you when I walked in you're doing
do something from South by Southwest or
something but I didn't know I did it I
didn't do anything with you said with
who I thought it was w kamau Bell I
could be wrong you're wrong by the way
that was Steve fine arts that was South
by Southwest Steve fine arts directed
that and he's done like in ruins with
Eddie Pepitone and he did such spy I'm
Showtime along with him but good for
them firing right I was I liked my
material but more than that I was so
happy with what he did with that so I
appreciate that compliment and I he just
edit it beautifully you know someone's
editing and they know comedy yeah yeah
damn it it's to let things breathe it's
the first time in my career where I
really have watched somebody edit comedy
that knows comedy and lets things
breathe and that's what I thought he did
with that showtime thing i really like
that i like to wait look yeah looks
great the crowd was darkness set was
just did a really nice job I do a lot of
writing for television and I have had
more than one editor save my ass on some
[ __ ] i have written and just the way
they added it is like oh thank you when
considers know what they're doing i say
it's it's editing mix with therapy maybe
just cuz the way it makes you feel but
like when they take something you do and
then you watch even the first draft and
you're like oh my right yeah all right
but you look very nice on that black
shirt do you always wear black I do I
just you know what it just I the obvious
that it was nice not to have to think
about what to wear yeah so I just go
with dark Levi jeans dark black shirt I
sweat I can't even more dark blue oh
really your sweater wet so I just wear
black you know I feel good cool pair of
shoes my listeners know and I've stopped
this might because i have a few
superstitions before I go on stage and I
used to wear the same outfit for the
week
and what was it it was whatever it
matter it didn't I had like four you
know shirts three pants that I went and
I wear this and unless for some reason i
tanked on Thursday then I changing it up
for friday but it's like it's the only
sports thing i do is you know like my
brother's a big jock and he like never
watched his jersey in the playoffs or
whatever so I would never put then after
about the ninth show and the twelfth
show run in Vegas you start stinking and
so now I change but I'm thinking about
learning i'm doing vegas next month i'm
thinking about wearing a suit i wish i
could wear a suit i love the way it
looks but i would sweat too much no i
haven't even thought about the sweating
butter i mean even if you got the latest
yeah material but still but i'm doing a
Netflix special in december and i really
i don't know maybe i won't wear a suit
but i don't i only want to wear one cuz
I just like the way it look yeah it
looks cool and um but um I think it
might be too hot from yeah where they
like I wear the jeans and then the blunt
shirt sometimes I have like a light
jacket that I'll wear this makes it feel
dressed up a little I were I were sued a
the irvine improv like last year and it
was awful and i felt uncomfortable and I
didn't like it and I didn't like the way
the suit fell on Gemini I had a tie then
I'm like hey why not its the new improv
it's 500 seats it's a new place let's do
this we so bad we're terrible but my
wife got me a suit and I worked to a
party other night and it felt great like
I felt good in it and I was like mom mom
hi I caught my wife mom why not a lot
what we were saying about therapy
earlier I'm like mayor I think I can
wear this on stage and she's like you
know where you gonna one like well maybe
Vegas you know she's like well don't
wear it to the [ __ ] ice house
everybody shows up in flip-flops you
know I'm thinking me and it's a three
piece it's a vest you know an N a jacket
fits them no tie no time you don't gotta
work all right I but I focus I'm
thinking about doing that I wish I could
do that like paul f tompkins the guy's a
great group so yeah beautifully but it's
just it would be too hot but i think if
i try like maybe getting a light light
light like it is suiting yet it might be
something like somebody we're in Miami
so it's like Sam salmon-colored linen
uh maybe like seersucker but it's all
black I don't know I'm really making
sure I know what rambling on about
though Todd I want to thank you so much
for doing this thank you I appreciate it
I know a lot about you now I know a lot
about you and you're a good guy thank
you I feel as if maybe uh I don't know I
might be flip putting the cart before
the horse here but maybe you should come
over for Christmas really yeah I'm there
you know you said on the phone that made
me laugh because it was solely go I
enjoyed our comfortable moments in our
comfortable moments you know you said
something about like our awkward silence
uh-huh sometimes like it's so weird i'll
get the very perceptive of you because
there is that sometimes i don't think
it'll happen anymore i feel but when I
meet people sometimes I get a little
nervous and sometimes I [ __ ] own the
room I walk into a room I feel
comfortable i use you know to my comfort
ability to relax everybody else i'm not
i'm not to but also sometimes and i do i
get around some people sometimes and I
get like awkward so when you pointed
that out I'm like ah what a perceptive
thing to say and that also made me not
feel awkward anymore right you were so
perceptive too well I didn't grace that
instead of like going you know it's all
good okay are you my I've intimidating
good looks and if you don't my lap if
you don't see the overbite which takes
it down it can be intimidating plus I
think when we ran into each other at the
improv the other night I was a little
drunk and so I was probably making
things awkward anyway so with the improv
we're at each other the improv League oh
you said the other night okay yeah I'm
listen i'm from the south the other
night could be last thursday or four
years ago so but this is before the
podcast festival so now we're good yeah
everything i think is working out in
christmas is gonna be nice yeah you do
Pollyanna or oh I don't know what that
means well where everybody you have you
don't know the pollyanna no no it's a
movie you if you have six brought your
family instead of you buy everybody a
gift haas the way we used to do it then
we went to Polly Ann a few years ago so
much easier now we just do the kids
which is not better right but a
Pollyanna means you pick a name out of a
hat and that's who you're responsible oh
I'm sorry should have been clearer it's
just gonna be on me oh wait like oh he's
got a wife and a kid will be nice it'll
feel like Christmas oh no doubt they
went out of town yeah they left me they
left me never never really got
studio apartment downtown yeah I own
your way over can you bring a tree
lights with rope yeah because I remember
you were talking about this it Todd is
very handy i just realized that also hey
man so where can we catch it was so
you're doing your Netflix special is
very exciting where you take them out
when does this drop sunday sunday it's
actually live uh today is Sunday
actually um I will be at the oh I'll be
at the DC improv halloween weekend Oh
actually getting ready for my special
and sort of running it as much as I can
and then I'm doing the velveeta room in
austin in no Austin did I say that's an
awesome yeah okay in austin de Velveeta
room i think it's i don't have the date
in front of me but it's like if you go
to the valve reader and website it's
like the second week in november i'm
very excited to do that because i love
our rooms gonna be great in a guy who
runs it is into it we're gonna make it
look so cool it's a great room and and
then i'll be in the philadelphia the day
after christmas at the comedy cabaret
and books gallery they're the only three
dates that are on my head oh I'm doing
you know what I'm doing that's gonna be
fun and I love doing this I'm doing all
Jim Gaffigan 'he's boston dates and then
I'm doing all Jim Gaffigan 'he's
Minneapolis dates okay that is always I
wouldn't want to just do 15 minutes all
the time right but it is pure joy doing
it one sometime it's just easy yeah it's
21 show go out to dinner you gotta meet
audience all warmed up it's a sweet spot
yeah oh thats kool cigarette Jim
Gaffigan yeah that's cool so there's my
date um what's in Bucks County the
comedy cabaret how long has that been
there 30 over 30 years that must be the
one my aunt keeps telling me about above
a Mexican restaurant called locos and
it's a I do my spin on it there's a club
I do my spin like you wouldn't oh really
yeah I should I tell you yeah I know
we're going to brick ah it sounds weird
but let me tell you something it doesn't
look a little better when I do it it's
at night and [ __ ] dry everything
lower lower the lights lower the lights
he's got signs on the wall that say
hypnotism classes he takes them all off
him he's happy to do it the week before
when they know i'm coming in sunday
night when they're doing their last show
saturday just go around their own
velcro takes all the signs off the walls
and lowers alight in the hallway black
tablecloths not you pulls it just night
and day I have it there 3-piece jazzman
so when people walk into the room it's
we gel a few lights red now it's a red
room no signs all over the place
three-piece band and black suits playing
jazz as they're being seated I love
transforming it's just it just you
people walk in there like holy [ __ ] and
if club's been there forever right it's
a lot of fun well I gotta just from
seeing you around town doing ten minutes
here and there and just parts of that
because I leave uh not because you cuz
you're in and out of the room that came
off dickish I apologize dude okay I
guess I want to check your full set man
that sounds awesome it's fun to
sometimes you know there's Caroline's in
New York we can go watch people data
sets maybe maybe it's true maybe it's
not true just seems like in LA I wish
there was a club like you know like you
get to see cuz i love to go see well I
guess you do you go see Eddie Pepitone
doing ours yeah yeah monitor Kinley's
yeah but um anyway all right I don't
know check it out all right Todd glass
thank you so much come check out Todd
when it comes to your tallies obviously
very funny thanks man thank you very
much for but life on the road it's a
taco dang Grigor strippers waving guns
and these flights canceled flights
running with the runs dome black this
bounced checks great bachelorette comes
in the front making out for your side
I was doing Baltimore missing merchant
try the rental car passed another mega
church dream juice keys vagina Pfister
cellphone is gone one big ball and order
marathon